what's going on reject nation thanks for
being here today we're going to watch
some cosmic wonder spider-man 3
first look shared by tom holland it's a
short video so let's
swing into it
what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk all things
marvel cinematic universe and today we
have some great news to start your
weekend off the right way
spider-man 3 has officially begun
filming
with the main cast tom holland is on set
filming as we speak right now we have an
actual set photo shared by tom holland
himself and that means spoilers are
going to be coming
very soon and uh
the website for production weekly
currently lists spider-man 3 and they
list it right now as
spider-man homesick now as far as the
title is concerned it's not a bad title
especially since we make sense that was
what we heard forever ago yeah on the
run and probably is not going to be able
to come home because he's going to be a
wanted fugitive for the murder of
mysterio and we know this because if we
take a look at the photo that tom
holland
shared today on instagram
took me a second i noticed the mask
you can see that this is the exact same
spider-man suit that we saw
at the very end of spider-man far from
home and this is a new photo of him
in the suit which means spider-man 3
spider-man homesick whatever we're
calling it right now is going to pick up
immediately after spider-man fart from
home which isn't that big of a surprise
but this pretty much confirms it so the
last time we left peter parker inspired
his identity was revealed and now
everybody knows that he's spider-man
mysterio also framed him for his murder
and all the attacks on the people as
well
and the last thing that spider-man said
was what the and then it ended so that's
where we left off and that's where we're
going to pick up from
immediately in fact i wouldn't be
surprised if the opening scene was
actually just a replay of the
post-credits scene where peter parker's
identity is revealed
then from there we'll see him go on the
run and he'll have to leave home
so homesick may indeed be the title but
we'll have to wait and see it should be
revealed pretty soon since they are
officially
filming now so let me know how excited
you are let me know what you think about
the possible title of spider-man
homesick be sure to let me know your
thoughts in the comments yeah don't
forget to subscribe some of the early
ones right
it makes sense i don't mean i'm not love
it but for live updates you can always
follow me on instagram and twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching
woof yeah we talked about the homesick
title before of
you know like having it makes sense he
who wants to be able to
to get back home in a peaceful way you
know essentially that's a homesick
implying i want to get back home i miss
home and i'm on the run
as far as this photo goes i mean it's
not a big surprise what we got here i
think it's kind of an adorable photo if
anything
it took me a second to notice the the
mask around
his other mask it took me a second to
notice that the spiderman mask yeah i
mean it's got to just be a photo that he
took for for this right like
it would be funny if i wore the mask
right this is literally what i was
sitting here thinking was
did they just immediately decide to
incorporate some kind of pandemic
reference or yeah was this just like a
quick
put a good mask on him for a half a
second so that we can take a little
promo shot
what if you know when people are filming
now that are constantly wearing masks
in between takes and stuff and
rehearsals what if they force tom
holland even
with the spider-man suit on you still
gotta wear a mask man
approved material for your spiderman you
gotta wear masks
you're gonna have to have more
protective material we're working on one
that's all made out of n95
or maybe if he is traveling if it is
homeworld still as part of the
spider-man 3 title
maybe he travels into our earth
yeah earth 2 0 2 0.
and that's right or everyone's right
i got to blend in let me wear a mask so
no one notices it
i like to think the title will be called
spider-man's my homeboy
and he takes up a penchant for like
graffiti tagging and this is just a
precaution so that he doesn't inhale the
harsh fumes
yeah that makes sense generous great
paint it's a great addition there as far
as i'm wearing the suit again goes we
know how the spider-man movies go
he's gonna have a different suit by the
end of the film yeah midway through
somewhere he'll definitely have a
different suit at some point it's bound
to get messed up
yeah yeah and it would make certainly
sense that he would start the movie off
in the last suit
given how immediate those circumstances
were all right guys well
spider-man 3. can't wait for the actual
title to come out
leave your thoughts down below what you
thought of this photo subscribe click
the notification bell
anything spider-man related sounds
exciting we'll be sure to check it out
[Music]